you've learned pretty much everything
you can about the other people in the
cast
well like okay I know everything I need
to know about you would think but there
are moments where things surprise you Ed
O'Neill and I were shooting a scene the
other day where we were both in a steam
room and and the joke is that Mitchell's
in the steam room and then like the
smoke the steam sort of clears me
realize his father's also in the steam
room but his father's naked so like
we're gonna do you know they're gonna
pixelate him and like but for shooting
purposes he was wearing a pair of like
nude colored underwear head O'Neal you
know the wonderful brilliant had O'Neal
sure Here I am like basically naked
without O'Neal and he's wearing his like
you know nude color underwear and we get
to the part of the scene where in
supposed to sort of glance over and look
at him and I noticed that Edie is huge
like distractingly massive I'm just like
so
I am nervous about looking against I
don't want it to think that I'm like
staring but it's hard not to look and
then I seem to sort of get he's a little
bit uncomfortably sort of fidgeting
around a little bit I was like oh my god
Edie has an erection what yeah and I was
like oh my god and then I started be
getting very protective of him was like
all the camera crews gonna see this he's
gonna be so embarrassed it's like stop
its erection I was like and everyone
sort of laughing and then he sort of
stands up and he's like still
readjusting and then I allow myself a
really good glance and he has stuffed
his underwear with the fake penis
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because he's not a jokester he's right
doesn't do pranks he doesn't do
something that's you know I want to go
home and just have a glass of wine and a
nice steak and call it a day he's not
like looking to like write play
practical jokes and write is so pleased
with himself
I was like the first thing I said was
like then Eric Stonestreet put you up to
this he's like no it was my idea he was
really proud of himself proud of himself
you